Hello, everyone out there on free co camp. My
name is Ania Kubow and I'm a software developer,
as well as your guide for this fun JavaScript
tutorial in this JavaScript tutorial,
we're gonna be building two words, games
that is a jeopardy game that I've adapted
to work well for one player and a game
of word association. This tutorial will
be for those who have learned the basics of
JavaScript. I just wanna practice some fun
games. Okay? So there'll be a lot of work with
objects, arrays loops and everything like that.
In fact, here is a full list of all the JavaScript
properties and methods we'll be using in this
tutorial. So let's dissect the first game. The
first game will be my adapted game of jeopardy.
As you can see here, the signing is very
basic. This is a JavaScript tutorial. Okay.
I won't be focusing that much on the style,
cuz that part is up to you in this game.
When you flip a card, you won't be able to flip
any of the other cards until you answer the
question. And if you answer correctly, you get
some points. And of course, if you don't well,
no points for you. And in the next game of word
association, you will have some cards which will
be populated from an array and you have to
essentially get the word associated with the
three tips above. If you get the answer, correct,
you get a point and if you don't, that's a minus a
point for you. The total amount of points will be
reflected based on the amount of correct and wrong
answers you choose. Okay. So what are we waiting
for? Let's get to practicing some JavaScript.
Okay. So let's get started. I'm gonna start off
with first off creating my project. I am using
WebStorm as my code editor or technique IDE of
choice, but please feel free to use whatever
code editor you wish such as FIS code or you
know, similar. Okay. So what I'm gonna do
is just go ahead and create a new project
and I'm gonna call this word association
Game. Okay. So that's all I'm gonna call it and
it's gonna be stored in my WebStorm projects
directory. And I'm just gonna go ahead and
click create. So there we go. You'll see
a directory called word association game that
has been created. The next thing I wanna do is
actually add the files necessary. So this is gonna
be an HTML file. Just gonna call this index HTML.
You can put the extension, but as I've chosen
the HTML file, it will just be added for me.
So there we go. We are telling our code
editor of choice to treat this as a HTML file.
Great. And we're just gonna
call this word a so ation.
Okay. Maybe let's make it a little bit bigger.
So there we have it. The next file we're gonna
create is for our style sheet. So I'm gonna click
style sheet and let's call the styles and I'm
just gonna select the CSS file for those of you
not using webstore just type CSS and that should
be created for you. So now our code editor knows
who treat this as a CSS file. One more and that
is a JavaScript file. So this one I'm just gonna
call app and hit enter once again, if you're not
using, webstore make sure to put in the dot JS
extension so that your code editor knows who treat
this as a JavaScript file. Great. So now that we
have all three files, what I need to do is connect
these two files to my index HTML file. So we're
gonna do so now with a link tag and a script tag.
So style sheets, we actually do this in between
the two ahead tags. I'm going to get the link tag
like so, so this is actually a self-closing tag
and I'm just going to put the rail as style sheet
and the ref is just gonna be the part of where our
style sheet lives. Well, it's in the root
of our project, so I'm just gonna type in
styles, CSS. Okay. We don't need to go
into any directories or anything like that.
It's just a very simple project. Everything
is just in here and now for the script tag.
So the script tag, we're gonna have to make
sure to put this at the bottom of our body.
So once any sort of, uh, I guess elements we
want to put in. So if we put in elements here,
we need to put the script tag afterwards. Okay.
So make sure that's at the bottom of your two
body tags. And I'm just going to put the source
again as the path to the app JS file. So great.
Now you will see some code being suggested for me.
So as you can see, this is being suggested for me,
if you aren't seeing this, this is because I am
using the tab nine, uh, extension, which will
give me next generation code snippet suggestions.
So if you aren't seeing that, don't worry. There's
nothing wrong with your code editor. It's
just a, uh, extension that I have installed.
Okay. So great. So we've linked up our style
sheet. We've linked up our app JS file. The next
thing to do is actually start adding some stuff
into my HTML file in order to start building up,
you know, the skeleton of our word associated
game, this is a JavaScript tutorial.
So the majority of our work is actually gonna be
done in the app JS file, but a small piece of, um,
HTML is still kind of needed. So I'm going to
put in a div, let's give this the class of app
so we can pick it out later in our CSS and style
it up. So here is our app and what do I wanna put
in the app? Well, I'm gonna have a question area.
So I'm gonna put diviv and give this the class of
question area like so, so that we can once again,
pick it out in our CSS file to style it up.
Now my question area, well, one thing I definitely
wanna have, and I don't wanna change is just going
to be, you know, the head of the app. This is
gonna say welcome to web association. Okay.
And then let's also have an H three tag, which
is gonna show us our score and this will change.
So I'm just gonna put your score is, and then
I'm going to use a span element. Okay. The span
element will allow us to interrupt this H
three tag in line. So it won't do anything
funky. It will still look like it's part of, you
know, I guess one sentence, uh, and these score
where we're gonna have to inject this with our
JavaScript, which is why I wanna pick out this
span element and I'm gonna do so by I giving this
an ID. So the ID I'm gonna give this is score,
display just like salt. So now I can
pick it out with my job script. Okay.
So we have the question area. It's got H one
tag, it's got an H three tag. The next thing I
wanna do is add a diviv and I'm gonna give this
the class so we can style it up of questions.
Okay. But I'm also gonna give this the ID so
we can also pick it out in our JavaScript.
We can pick it out by class, but it's
just neater, I think, to do it by IDs.
But again, each to your own, there's so many ways
you can code this game. It's absolutely crazy.
So we've given it a class so we can silo up.
We've also given this ID so we can pick it out
in our JavaScript. And essentially what we're
gonna be doing is injecting. We're gonna be
injecting elements into here using JavaScript.
So I hope you're excited for this. That's why
we're picking this out. We're gonna be literally
appending elements into here, all in here. Great.
So we're pretty much done with this page.
Now let's move on to the app JS file. So
the first thing I said we're gonna do
is just pick out this element, right?
Well, we're gonna pick up both these elements.
Maybe let's start with these score first.
What should we save this? As I'm gonna say,
this is score display. It's gonna make it a
little bit bigger for you. We can actually
minimize this. So score display. I'm gonna
use document. Cause I'm looking in the entire
HSL document. The whole thing I'm gonna use,
get element by ID and I'm gonna get it by score
display, making sure it's spelled exactly the same
way that we spelt it here. So now we've picked
out this entire thing. Okay. Because we're gonna
want to inject the score into here. The same for
the question display, because we're gonna inject
elements into here. So what should we call
this? Well for consistency, I'm just gonna call
it question display. And if I hit enter, that's
actually been auto completed for me by tab nine.
So there we go. We are picking things out.
We're saving them as cons so that we can use
them later on in our code. So great. So now
that we have that, let's carry on. The first
thing I actually wanna do is actually just write
some questions that we're gonna be, you know,
displaying in our wide association game. So I'm
gonna show how to do that. It's gonna be an array.
So I'm gonna call this constant questions and make
an array and it's gonna be an array of objects.
Okay. So each object is gonna contain, you
know, the actual, uh, words. So you're gonna
have three words and then we're gonna have to
pick a answer based off two words that the, um,
word is most associated with. I
didn't explain that very well,
but hopefully I'm gonna show you now how to do it.
And then we're also gonna tell ourselves, which
is the correct score. So for example, if I have
three words and those words are gonna be value,
and then the next word is gonna be estimate, and
then the third word is gonna be a value. Wait,
so we've got three words as the quiz words, and
then our options to select from, as in which word
is most likely, uh, associated with these three
words. Well, the first one I'm gonna put is jury,
which doesn't really make sense, right? Jury
isn't associated with these three words,
however assess is okay. So the viewer is gonna
see these three words and then have the option
of these two to pick which one is more associated
with these three. So, and then I'm also gonna put
the correct answer is option two out of
these, we could go by index zero or one.
It's up to you. I'm not going to just
purely because, uh, I do do this video
in, on my personal channel using an API. And
that API actually happens to use this format.
So not using indexes, but just simply saying
that option one is not correct, but option two
is correct. So that's why I've done it this way.
Again, it's up to you how you would like to do it.
So there's our first question. Let's go ahead
and create some more. So for now, I'm just gonna
make a few, of course you can have as many as you
like, like I did say I do do this tutorial on my
own channel using an API that actually gets loads
and loads of questions. There's a huge amount. So
if you wanna check it out, please do use the
link in my description below in order to, uh,
essentially get the link for this a tutorial.
Okay. So these are just hard coded for
us as I mentioned. Okay. So I'm just going to
paste another three that I pre-made earlier.
So there we go. Okay. Those three, I've just
pasted in, please pause here if you need, or
the code will be available in the description
below as well. So those are my five questions
along with the correct answers. Okay. So where
now you're gonna use this array in order to
create a new elements using loops. Okay. So
this means if you wanna add more questions,
then you know, each the elements will
be easily created for us and so on.
So the first thing that I'm gonna do is, well
actually let's start with the score. So the
score is gonna change, which is why I've used let,
and now it's not good enough just saying that the
score is zero. We're gonna have to actually
put it into our HTML and we're gonna do so.
Cause we've already picked out this score display.
So I can use this context and I'm gonna use
text content and I'm just gonna use these score
variable. Okay. So that's all I've done and now
making sure that's just one equals. And now if
I view this, I'm just going to open this up in
WebStorm. I can actually just use this button
right here and I will open it up in my browser.
Okay. So you will see the score has been added
TA wonderful. Uh, for those of you not using
WebStorm you can just copy the path. So
you'd copy the path here and then paste
it in your browser. So I'm just gonna do it,
uh, for you. I'm gonna get the absolute path
and then paste it in here. Like, so it's the same
thing. Great. I was gonna minimize this again.
So wonderful. So we are showing the score.
The next thing that we're gonna do is write
a function to populate the question. So
just like we got the score display here,
we're gonna now get the question display
and populate it with questions. So I'm
gonna do this all in a self-contained function.
However, so the function is gonna be called Pope
questions. Okay. It's just
what I've chosen to call it.
Now we're going to actually use four each.
So essentially a loop in order to create a
bunch of DS that are gonna be our question. Boxes
are gonna hold all the question stuff together.
So based on how many items I have in this array,
so I'm gonna get this array. So I'm getting the
array. I'm gonna use four each and for each
item in my array. Now we know there's five
items I'm gonna choose to call those items. Each
one of them a question. So for each item, which I
have chosen to core question, what I wanna do is
essentially create an element. I wanna create a
diff, okay. And let's just save this as question
box so we can use it in a JavaScript const
question box. Now I'm actually gonna add
a class list so we can do so with class
list add, and I'm gonna add the class of question
box to the div that we just created.
Okay. So that is how you would do it.
You would use this method in order to add the
question box class. So the div we just created,
of course we won't be able to see anything
quite yet. We haven't styled any divs and
we haven't actually put that div back into the
HTML. So I'm gonna show you how to do that next.
So for now, what can we do? Maybe let's start
up the question box just so we can see things
visually first. So I'm just going to maybe make
this a little bit bigger and grab the question
box, like, so, and let's do some styling.
So my question boxes at the moment, I'm just
gonna give them a background color. Uh, I'm just
going to use an RGB color for this, just like
so, and give each one a margin of 15 pixels. Okay.
So that's all I am going to do just so we can
start seeing some things. So we've created a
div, we added the class of question box to it,
which is essentially just make it black or the
margin. The next thing we're gonna do is put the
question box into our question display so
we can do so let's get the question, display
display, and I'm gonna use a pen to put in the
question box. Okay. And then I'm just gonna call
the function. So I'm just gonna call it to
make this work. And now if I refresh this,
you will see, there are five question boxes in
here. We need to put something in them in order to
actually see that they are black. So all I'm gonna
do is go back in here and for now, just so you can
see that this is actually working, I'm just gonna
put box. Okay. So just put in the string of box.
So there we go. Box, box, box, perhaps, maybe
let's, you know, give this text, let's make
it white, just so we can see what is going on
fat. I'm just gonna make it slightly off white.
So RGB 2 30, 2 30, 2 30. Great. So amazing. We
are looping in order to get question boxes made
for each of our questions let's carry on. So
hopefully that makes sense, because we're gonna
be using this logic a lot in this tutorial. We're
just gonna be kind of repeating this in order to
create more elements. Okay, great. While we are
here, I'm actually just going to grab the app
itself. So the diviv of the class of app, just
to make sure that everything is centered and I'm
actually gonna apply the font family of Trabu
sounds to it as well. So, so tra butcher, Ms.
Sorry. Uh, and then just some backup ones, two.
So maybe let's have Lucinda Grande for Donna.
Sure. Those ones. So to center, everything I'm
gonna use display flex. So this is flex box.
Okay. You have to use display flex in order to
do these next few lines. Otherwise they will not
be applied. So justify content comes with flex
box and then text align does not actually come
with flex box. So text aligned center, that's
just the center or the text, and I'm gonna give
it a padding of hundred pixels. So the app
is gonna have a PA of a hundred fix pixel.
Great. And now the question boxes live
in the questions. Diviv right. So we're
inserting them in here. So I'm just gonna
style up this diviv a little bit too.
I just wanna make sure I'm gonna use flex
box again, by the way, I'm use display flex.
And I just wanna make sure that they wrap.
Okay. So if you change the size of your screen,
they kind of wrap over each other and you do so
with flex wrap wrap, and I'm also gonna center
them. So justify content center. Wonderful. And
I'm just gonna start the question box a little bit
more. Um, let's make, give them a border radius.
I'm a big fan of the border radius. Not to make
things look harsh. I think it's always like quite
a nice thing to do. I think three is fine. Maybe
let's go for 10 pixels. I'm also gonna give a
padding, but the padding's not gonna be equal.
I'm gonna give it padding zero from the top
40 pixels, uh, to the right 10 pixels on the
bottom and 40 pixels to the left. Okay. So that's
what I've done. Great. So that is our question
box looking good. And if we look in here,
it just kind of looks more like that now.
Okay. So each question box is ready to have our
questions be actually put into them as well as,
you know, some buttons, uh, and so on. So
let's continue. So back here. So instead of
having this just say box, we're actually going
to use four each to show each of the three quiz
words from array. Okay. So we're gonna do that
next. So again, this is gonna be a four each we're
gonna go into the questions, array we're then
gonna go into the array and then find the quiz
key. And then we're gonna use four each and for
each one of these, what should we call this?
I guess it's a tip, right? We can call it a tip
for each tip. So tip, we are going to essentially
create a PTAG so document create element
and the element we wanna create is a PAG.
Okay. So that's all I'm gonna do.
And let's save this as constant tip
text. Okay. Again, you can call it whatever you
wish. So we've created a P tag. The next thing
we're gonna do is add a, uh, we're not gonna
add a class lips. We're gonna get the tip text,
and we're going to use text content. You can use
inner HTML, it's whatever you wanna do. And then
we're just going to assign the tip itself. Okay.
So we're just gonna assign fast and then quick and
then prompt. Okay. And then finally, of course
we need to put it in something, but we wanna
put it in the question box this time. Okay. The
question box we put into the question display,
but into the, okay. So let's go back here.
The question box. This thing is looking here.
So I'm going in, here's our HTML. And then we
grab this, this is the question display. And
we inject these question boxes. Now in each
question box, we also wanna inject the tips.
Right. So we're gonna do that. So I'm going
to this time, get the question box that we
created up here and I'm gonna use a pen
tip text. Okay. So now if we look in here,
so once again, see, we are just adding elements,
adding them using JavaScript. So now each question
box has P tags with are tips. Great. Okay. So
hopefully this is solidifying a bit more, the more
we do it let's carry on. I also wanna put in a
logo. So let's do that above here. So before these
get injected in the question box, cause these
Jews kind of stack up when you inject things. So
you need to make sure that whatever order, uh, you
wanna put things in has to go from top to bottom.
So let's call this logo. Um, yeah, let's just call
it all logo display. Sure. And I'm gonna create
a element actually let's make an H one tag because
our logo's actually just gonna be some symbol.
Okay. Off the internet. <laugh> of course you
don't have to, you can make an image or something,
but what I'm gonna do go logo display.
So I'm gonna grab this logo display,
and I'm gonna use text content, and I'm gonna
use this, uh, because it's a word association
game. I'm gonna use this pen symbol right here.
Okay. So that's all I've done. It's just a text
symbol. So we've added that. And of course,
once again, we need to put it in the question
box. We're gonna get our question box and we're
gonna append. You can append child append actually
allows you to add multiple things, uh, where
child just allows you to append one, I believe.
And the thing we're gonna append is the logo
display after we've added some text to it. So
great. So once again, if I refresh this, there
is our logo. Cool. Of course we can style it up
as well. If we wish simple way to do this without
giving this a class name, actually so that we,
you know, we don't want too much, too much
overkill is I can actually go into the question
box and any H one tag that lives in it will have
this styling. So I'm just gonna make it go left
by going a line text line left, and let's maybe
change its color two. So I'm gonna go RGB 1 77,
1 3 6 2 1 1. Okay. But of course, if you
put in any H one tags into the question box,
this will have the same sting. So just keep
that in mind. But otherwise it looks like this.
Great. So we have our tips. The next thing
we'll do is our two buttons that will
show us the two, uh, potential answers we could
have. So let's do that next. So we've just added
the tips here and we are putting the question box
into the question displays, but before we do that,
we need to do some more stuff. So the next thing
I wanna do is actually create a diviv that will
store our two buttons so that we can keep them
together. So I'm gonna use document, create
element, and we're gonna create a div D just
like so, and let's store this as question
buttons. Is this gonna hold our question buttons?
Uh, and this time I will actually be adding a
class list to this. So question buttons, class
list, add question buttons. Thank you. Tab nine.
And of course also we need to append it.
So this time I'm just gonna go grab the question
box again and append question buttons. Okay.
So we've put in the div that has the class of
question buttons into the question box. The next
thing we need to do is add some actual buttons
into the questions, buttons this time. So
I wanna do this. We are still in the loop.
So if you can see here for each question with make
sure you're still in between these curly braces,
cuz we're looping over each one of these. Okay.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, and in the loop, I want to get
the options. Okay. So we've called each item in
the loop question, which means that I'm gonna get
the question quiz and for each quiz item, what
do we want to call this for each fast for each
option? Let's call it. Well, what do
I want to do? I wanna create a button.
So let's use document, create element button.
I'm gonna save this as the constant question
button. Okay. So singular this time. So we're
essentially creating two buttons as we have two
items in the quiz array. And now I'm just gonna
give this a class list. So question button,
class list. Add question button singular. Okay.
Well of course we are yet to write this class
and I'm just gonna give it some text
content too, so we can see what's going on.
Question button, text, content,
and that's gonna be the option.
Okay. And of course let's not forget that we
need to actually append this into the question
buttons. So I'm gonna put it in
here. Question buttons, append the
question button singular. Okay. So it's gonna loop
once. It's gonna put in the first one, it's gonna
loop a second time. It's gonna put in the second
one after we've course, we assign it the class
list and assign it the actual option itself.
So let's have a look in here and
oh, we've picked the wrong thing. I mean,
that's good. Right? We are figuring this
out. It's not questions, quiz. It's question.
It's options. So each of the questions, options,
so TA so we are doing it. We have our two options.
This is looking good. Let's take a break from
some JavaScript and start this up a little bit
more. Okay. Because we still have a bit to do
we need to add an event listener to the question
button itself. That's gonna check for answers,
disabled buttons. Make sure we can't click on
a button again and so on. So let's take a quick
break and relax our brains with some styling. So
let's actually pick out the question buttons and
question button to style up. So I'm just
gonna use the class of question buttons
and I wanna make sure that everything in
here. So the two buttons that we created
are gonna be next to each other. So I'm gonna use
display flex. And just to be sure, I'm gonna give
it a flex direction of not column but row.
And now for each individual question button,
I'm gonna give each one, a margin of five pixels,
Some padding, 10 pixels from the top and
bottom and 20 from the left and right,
I'm gonna give it a border radius,
which is going to be 20 pixels.
Make sure to spell that correctly. I'm gonna
say border nuns. We get rid of the generic,
uh, button styling and then background color.
I'm just gonna go with RGB 75 1 3 4 1 1 1.
Okay. And the text is just gonna be
white, but I would like to make it RGB.
So maybe just make a tiny bit off
white RGB, 2 5, 5, 2 5, 5, 2, 5, 5.
Great. However, if we also then get the, uh,
question button and if we add disabled to it,
this is gonna be for later. I actually want
the background color to be like a dark gray
RGB, 8, 9 1 8 9 1 8 9. Something like
that. Maybe even a little bit darker.
Okay. Of course that hasn't happened
yet. But when we do disable the buttons,
uh, because we will be doing that, that's
just what I wanna do. And then also the text,
I wanna look kind of like this grayish as
well. So it looks like we can't click on it.
Great. So now let's carry on. This is
what our buttons should look like right
now. Okay. And you can see, these are wrapping
just like, so I'm just gonna make this movie a
little bit smaller or a little bit bigger. It's
totally up to you. How you wanna view this.
Let's move on. So now that we have that, let's
actually add, uh, an event listener to our buttons
so that it handles checking for results. So we're
gonna do that here. So again, we're gonna grab the
question button. So the question button that we
just created and use ad event listener to listener
for clicks. And if a click is done, we wanna check
answer. So this is a callback function that we are
yet to write. Okay. In fact, just for now, I'm
just gonna do this down here. I'm gonna write
function, check, answer, and I'm just gonna
console log checked just so we can see this
is working. Okay. But again, expect this page, get
the console log up. And if I click on any button,
it'll say checked, see, checked, checked,
checked, check, check, check, checked.
So we know that has been hooked up.
The event listener is working. Let's carry
on. Now. We don't just want the console log to say
something, right? What do we wanna happen? Well,
let's think about it. I actually want to check if
the answers correct. And we already have this data
stored in an array. And if it is correct, I wanted
to say correct below. Or if it's wrong, I wanted
to say wrong. And I also wanna disable the button
cause we clicked on it. We can't click it again.
And if it's correct, I wanna add a score and
if it's wrong, I wanna minus score. Okay. So by
the end you have a final score. That's based off
how many wrong and right answers that you have.
Cool. So let's do it. Let's do all of that logic
next. So to do this, I'm actually gonna have to
pass some things through, into my check answer
function. So I'm gonna pass some things through.
So I've gotten it open, not by parenthesis, but
uhoh this means I'm calling the function. It's not
a callback function anymore. So we need to do this
to make it a callback function. Okay. Otherwise
this will just check, answer without me clicking.
It'll just be like blah open. Cuz obviously we're
using parent parenthesis. So it's going like
and releasing all of its function wonderfulness.
So make sure to write that in order to
make this a core back function again,
and the things we're gonna have to pass
through are, well, let's have a think about
this. I actually wanna pass through,
well, I wanna pass through the,
I definitely wanna pass through the option.
So by that means, I wanna pass through this.
I'm gonna pass through this
and then I'm also gonna pass
through whichever index. This is because we know
that for example, this is the correct answer,
right? It says two. So we're
gonna pass through the questions,
correct answer. Also gonna pass through the
option that we clicked and then it's index value.
Okay. Where it sits in this array. So let's do
that now. So we're gonna have to give this an
index. So I'm gonna choose to call this option
index. So for example, I'm just gonna show you
what I mean by this. I'm
gonna pass through the option
and I'm gonna pass through the option index and
here I'm just going to console log the option
that I've passed through. So
let's pass through the option
and then let's also console log the option index.
Okay. And if I go in here, let's click on
option one, two click. So option we clicked
on is assess the option is passing through the
option. Index is not to find why is that? Let's
go back here passing through the option index.
Ah, but we're not passing it through into the
check answers function. So now let's click on
this one. Great. The option is assessed and the
option index is one because this says option index
zero. Okay. So each of them, this would be 0 1
0 1. You can check it. That's what
it should be. So we want a way to say
that, you know the correct an we also pass through
the correct answer. So let's go ahead and do that.
We need the questions, correct answer. So we know
this is either gonna be a one or a two, right?
So let's change the option index. Let's add plus
one to it. So instead of dealing with indexes,
we're just literally going, it's either option
one or two. So that correlates with the way that
we are counting the correct answer here. So
it's one or two. So we just need to know that
if this equals this, then it's correct. Right.
So let's pass that through. I'm gonna name it.
Something else here. Because as long as it's in
the correct order, it's uh, we don't have to call
it the same thing. In fact, it'll be probably less
confusing if we just call this the correct answer.
Right? Okay. So this means that
if I'm just gonna move this up,
if option index equals the correct
answer, doesn't really need to be strict.
Then we know that it is well correct. Let's just
put that back in there cuz it's shouting at me. So
then we'll just add one to the score, right?
And of course we need to display the score.
So score, display, text content score,
because otherwise we add into the score,
but we're not updating our browser to show
the new score. So that line is important.
Okay. So that's all I am doing else. If it's not,
we're gonna minus one from the score. And again,
we need to show this new score, right? Cause it's
not good enough just updating the score and here
we need to actually show that in the browser two.
Great. So let's check it out. So if I click assess
cool, I get one to the score cause it's right.
And if I click jewelry, well minus has been added
because we know that is wrong. So this is working,
this is looking good. However, look we can cheat,
right? And also be quite nice to disable the
button if we've clicked on it already. So let's
work on disabling the buttons now to do this,
we're actually gonna have to collect which items
we have already clicked. So I'm going to make
an array. Let's go ahead and maybe do that here.
So let clicked. So we might wanna, you know,
change that could be con let's just keep it as
let for now just because I'm not exactly sure
what I wanna do with this yet. So here's our array
and if we click on something, well, no matter
if it's right or wrong, I'm just gonna put it
in the array. So here's my array. I'm gonna
push the option in. So this means actually
I'm just gonna console log out the clicked array
for us here. So no matter if it's right or wrong,
we're just collecting things in our clicked array,
right. We're collecting them so that we know this
is clicked and we're gonna disable buttons.
Thanks to this. So great. Just get rid of that.
So this means that actually, maybe let's
pass through the question button in here
as well into the check answer function. So the
actual button itself, because we can do that.
You can do pretty much anything. And
now we're gonna get the question button
and disabled, uh, is not gonna be true. We're
actually going to look in the clicked array.
And if the clicked array includes the option,
then we know. So the option that we clicked,
then we know that the button should be disabled.
So let's try it out. Click. Oh, it's disabled.
Click disabled. Yes. This is looking awesome.
How cool is it's amazing. So great. Now one last
thing, it would be quite nice to have, you know,
like a display right or wrong under here. Right.
So that we know immediately if we are right or
wrong. So I'm gonna show you how to do that now,
in fact, okay. We are going to create,
<affirmative> create. So at the bottom,
once we've put in everything, I'm actually gonna
create, put in another diviv that's gonna show our
answer. So I'm gonna do so right at the
bottom here. So I'm gonna use document,
create element. I'm gonna create a div this
time and I'm gonna call it, answer display,
And we're gonna get the answer display. And I'm
going to give it the class list, class list, add
of answer display, which we're gonna start up
later. And of course we need to put this into
our question box. So question box, append, answer
display. And now let's style it up a little bit.
Perhaps we should just, we can do
that. So I'm gonna get in my CSS file.
Let's get our answer display. And I'm going to
just actually hard code a height for this. So
no matter if it's empty or not just gonna have
the same height and I'm just going to center
everything in here. So once again, I'm gonna
use flex box display, flex align items, center
justify content center. So there we have it.
Okay. So we've got our answer display and now
I'm just gonna make this smaller again. I'm
actually going to write another function. So
there's our function check answers. We're gonna
get function, get results, or maybe add results
cuz that's what we're technically doing.
Adding the result into the answer display.
So function add result. Well, what do we wanna
do? Well, this time I'm actually going to,
Based on the question box we are in. So when
do we want to call this function? I guess we
wanna call it after here. Right? We wanna do
it here or if we do it based on. So if we are,
if it's the correct answer, we're gonna add the
score and we can pass through the actual question
box. Right? Cause we wanna add it
to the question <affirmative> box.
Yeah. So let's get the, all
we could do. Answer display.
Yeah. Let's pause through the answer display.
So you've got the question box. I'm gonna pause
through the answer display as well into check
answer. And we're gonna say that we're gonna add
the results to the answer display and that result
is going to correct. Okay. Which means that again,
we can just use the same function to pass through
different variables to change the outcome.
So let's have this say wrong.
<affirmative>
Okay. So this means that we know we're passing
through the answer display and we're also gonna
pass through the actual answer. Okay. So this
means we can grab the answer display, uh, and
then we can use text content. In fact, we probably
wanna clear anything that's in there, right?
Because otherwise we'll just be adding more.
We'll be adding correct wrong, correct wrong.
Depending on which one we click. Cause it'll keep
adding. So we wanna clear anything that's in it.
And then we wanna get the answer, display, text,
content, and chooses to put the answer that we
pass through. Okay. As the second parameter. Okay.
So we're, we're gonna either pass your correct or
wrong depending on if we're here or if we're
here. Okay. So that's all I am going to do.
And I feel this should be it because we're already
putting in the want to display into the question
box up here, but let's check it out. So jury
let's see answer display. No, it seems we are not
putting that in here. Answer display, answer
display, just to see what we are clicking.
So if we click on here, answer display adjacent,
Ah, because we're adding the answer display here
because it needs to be after the options. We can't
then obviously add it in here. That's my bad.
So what I'm going to do instead is pass
through the question box. We've just created
inter check answer, because we can pass that
through. And then that means we are passing
that through inter check. So let's get rid
of this and pass through the question box,
which means that on the ad results, we're gonna
pass through the question box, pass through the
question box. This is a question box and it means
that we are going to get question box and get
the, uh, Bo or we can use query selector,
actually query selector to find the div with the
class name of answer display. So before, if you
notice, uh, dis looking in the entire document,
you can actually just look in a, uh, element. So
that's what I've done here. And let's save this
as answer display. So we don't want document
again. We wanna look in the question box.
Okay, cool. In fact, we might not actually need
this cuz it overrides it. So just get rid of that
And <affirmative> and great. So this is looking
good. One last thing I wanna do in that is just
change the color of this based on if it's right
or wrong. But this is super, super simple. All I'm
gonna do is of course get the answer display. Uh,
I'm just gonna remove any class list
that might exist. So if wrong exists,
I wanna remove it cuz otherwise it will just
add, you know, it might cause some funky issues.
So remove if there's a wrong class or a correct
class, remove both of those and I'm gonna get the
answer display and use class list add, and I'm
just gonna add, well actually we can just pass
it through in here to make our lives easier.
So the class name I wanna add is correct. And
if it's wrong, the class name I wanna add is
wrong. So I'm gonna pass through class name
and just use that to add a class name. And
there's also means of course we need to
do it here so we can make sure that it's just
on the answer display if I do. Correct. So there
you go. This means that it's on the same div. The
class is on anything with the class answer display
And the color of the text is gonna be RGB 2
0 1 2 0 1 1 1 7. And then I'm also gonna do
answer display wrong and wrong is gonna be 2
1 1 1 3 4 1 1 7. Okay so great. There we go.
We have now finished our game. Okay. It's kind
of foolproof because we are disabling buttons.
So you can't cheat. I don't think, uh, but let
me know what you think of this game. Okay. So
wonderful. We've just finished our game in pure
vanilla JavaScript. If you are interested in
taking this a step further and you like to learn
how to use APIs in order to get random questions
and please do check out the video. As I said in
the description below for this on my own channel.
Okay. So I'm gonna start off on
WebStorm, which is my IDE of choice
is the code editor that I'm gonna be
using today. And I'm just gonna click
new project right here and let's
call this jeopardy. So jeopardy,
Vanilla JS, just like so, and I'm just gonna click
create. So there you will see a directory has been
created for me. Of course there is nothing in this
directory at the moment, we're gonna have to add
some files. So I'm just gonna go ahead and add a
new file. There's gonna be an HTML file. I'm just
gonna call it index and select that it's a HTML
file. Now, if you aren't using WebStorm, you will
have to put the extension so that your code editor
knows to treat this as a HTML file, but we are
using WebStorm. So I'm just gonna go like that.
Great. And now let's call our project something.
This is what it's gonna display in the browser.
So I'm just gonna go ahead and call this jeopardy.
And now let's create some more files because
we're gonna have to sort our style somewhere.
So I'm just gonna go in here, create a new file
this time it's gonna do a style sheet. It's a
CSS file. I'm gonna call this styles and select
that it's a CSS file. So there we go. And you can
see the extension has been added. Wonderful. And
one more file. This is gonna hold our JavaScript
and I'm just gonna call it up. And as you'll see,
the JS extension has been added to our code editor
knows who treat this as a JavaScript file. Great.
Okay. Now I'm just gonna make this a little bit
bigger. We need to link up the two files we made
to the CMR file. So we're gonna do this thanks to
the link tag, just like so, and the reference to
this is just gonna do the path to my style's CSS
file, which is in the root of my project.
So I don't need to worry about going into
any directories or anything and it just looks
like that. And next, we also need to link up our
Java script and we're gonna do so with a script
tag and the source of this. We're also gonna give
the path to our app JS file. So just like that.
Okay. Making sure that it's above any HTML that
we write, because this needs to be loaded
first. Now in here, I'm just simply gonna
put the bare minimum of what we need and that is
gonna be an H one tag. That's gonna say let's play
Jeffrey. Okay. So just like that. And I'm going
to now make a diff that is gonna hold all of the
game in it. Okay. We're gonna be injecting
stuff with JavaScript into here. So we of
course need to pick this out and which is
why I'm gonna give this the ID of game.
Okay. And we're gonna be injecting stuff with our
JavaScript. We're gonna be injecting it exactly in
here in between these two dips, but I will show
you that later on. So we've got the diviv with
the idea of game. The next thing I'm gonna do is
just put an H two tag. That's gonna show our score
and I'm gonna use a span tag so that we can add
in the score dynamically later on. Okay. So for,
to do this, I'm gonna have to pick this out. I'm
gonna have to pick it out, um, in my JavaScript,
which is why I've given it the ID. And I'm just
gonna give this the idea of score. Okay. So by
using the span, it will just interrupt this H
two tag and it'll appear just like one sentence.
Great. So now that we've done that in
WebStorm I can just click this button
and it'll open up the game and the browser
for me, or if you are not using WebStorm,
you can just open this up by yourself.
You just need to right. Click here, copy the path,
make sure it's the absolute path and then just
paste that in your browser. Like so, so you're
literally going to wherever your index HTML file
is on your computer. Okay. And opening it up.
Great. And if I inspect the page, this will
allow me to get up my console log to carry on
coding. So let's carry on coding. Let's get to
adding our elements with JavaScript into here.
So to do this I'm of course going on to pick out
this diviv I'm gonna pick it out based by its ID.
And I'm gonna do the same for this one right
here. So the span element too. So in here,
we're gonna use document, get element I
can do by ID. Why not by ID game? And I'm
gonna save this as something, what should we
choose to save as let's just save it as game
and let's do the same for the score.
So I'm gonna call this score, display document,
get element by ID and the ID was score. So now
we've essentially saved these two elements. So
the span and this so that we can work with it in
our JavaScript based on these const. Okay, great.
So before we carry on, let's actually get
some data. So of course we are just making
a game using vanilla JavaScript. If you do wanna
learn how to use APIs, build out a backend and so
on. Uh, I do have a link to making this exact same
game just with a open API. So we won't have to do
any backend work for this particular one, but
I'll show you how to use fetch and just make an
API request in order to get a lot more data that
we're gonna be hard coding in here. Okay. So we're
just gonna, hardcode an array of genres, five
genres that have three questions, each ones, each
so jeopardy category, I'm gonna save
this as categories and this array is
gonna hold essentially our, uh, categories.
So the genre, the first genre is gonna be
who, and then each genre is also gonna have
its own questions, which is gonna be an array
of objects. So there's gonna be fun. There's
gonna be a lot of like interesting stuff that
we're gonna be working with today, especially for
YouTube working with arrays and objects and data.
So the next genre I'm gonna
actually have as where,
and I'm just gonna have an empty
array for the questions as well.
Okay. And we're gonna have five of these. Uh,
in fact, I'm just gonna show you what the first
object looks like, because all five are
gonna have the same kind of, uh, shape.
So the questions in my questions, array, like
I said, there's gonna be three questions. Each,
each one is gonna be symbolized by an object and
the object's gonna look like this. It's gonna
have the question itself. So for example, we can
have who wrote Harry Potter? That's my question.
And then of course we'll have two answers we can
choose from. So I know in jeopardy you were just
meant to shadow the answer, but of course this
is an online game. So I've just chosen to have
two answers available to the user playing and then
we'll show the correct answer. So JK rolling's one
answer, and then we're gonna have J R R Tokin
as the second answer. And then we're also gonna
have the correct answer, which in this case
is gonna be JK rowing, making sure to spell
exactly the same. Otherwise this will cause
issues even with the capital letters and so on.
It needs to be exact. And then the level we're
gonna have easy. Okay. So this is what we're gonna
have. This is how our question's gonna look.
We're gonna have three in each object genre.
So I've actually pre-done this for you because you
don't really wanna sit here watching me type up
all the data I presume. So I'm gonna just paste
it in here, like so, so there we go. As always,
this will be available in the description below,
the final code will be available. So please don't
worry. So I'm just gonna talk you through this
under the genre who we have an array of questions.
So here's the opening, uh, bracket to array and
there's three questions. One would level easy,
one would level medium and one level hard. And
then we got the next object, which is exactly the
same this time. The genre is where though, and
the questions are more around where, but again,
they have the answers available, the correct
answer, which is exactly the same down to the,
uh, capitals and not capitals. And then the
level. And then we have when, and then we have
what, and then we have how many, okay, so please
feel free to pause here and have a look at this
data once again, get it from the description.
Just make sure you're comfortable with it
before we carry on working with this data
in order to build out our jeopardy game.
So the first thing I wanna do is add a
category, right? So we've got our five
jeopardy categories and I'm gonna use each of
the categories in order to create a column. The
column is gonna have the name of the category
and then each three of the questions. Okay.
So that's what I'm gonna do.
There's gonna be a lot of four each
and loops in loops. Okay. Cuz we're gonna
loop out five columns that we're gonna
loop in each column, the questions and so on.
So I'm gonna show you how to do that. Now let's
go and get you writing our first function.
So I'm gonna write function, add category
and what do we wanna do? Well, actually, let's get
this array. I'm gonna get the jeopardy categories,
jeopardy categories. And for each let's call
it a category. I'm just gonna pass it through,
into the add category function.
Okay. So essentially all of this,
here's our first category, right? From here to
here, all of this is being passed through now into
this ad category function, but we're not
doing anything with it yet. Let's actually
pass it through. Now we need to get the
category genre first. Okay. So that's
what we're gonna do and we're gonna make
a title element with it. So let's do it.
So the first thing I'm gonna do is actually use
document, create element in order to create a
diviv and let's save this as something, I'm gonna
call this as a column. Okay. We're gonna create a
column. And in fact, we're gonna get that column
and use classless, add a class of column so we
can style it up later in our style sheet. So
that actually looks more like a column and
not just a div, in fact, maybe let's be more
precise and cool this genre column like so,
so we made a div. The first thing I said we wanna
put in the column is a, like a div for a title.
So I'm just going to use document, create element
diviv again, thank you. Tab nine. And let's call
this genre title and this time genre title,
let's give it class list, add genre title.
So we can again, style it up. And I'm just going
to use inner text to actually give it the genre
name. So like I said, we're going into here and
getting the genre. Okay. So we're getting the
string of who and then what and why and so on. So
all five categories. So that's all I'm doing, even
though at the moment, you won't see anything in
the browser, right? Because we're, we've created
elements. We've given them class names, we've put
some text inside them. Okay, we've done all that,
but we haven't actually put it back into our
HDML. Haven't we, we need to do that now.
So this is why I picked out the game. So this
is why I picked out this. Cause I wanna put
my first five columns that I'm making into here.
So I'm gonna do so like, so I'm gonna loop over.
So as soon as I make a column, I'm gonna get
the game. I'm going to use a pen to put in the
column we just made. So that will loop for each
time we have that. So we'll go five times, we'll
add a column and it'll add another column. Five
times that'll do it. But our column also needs
to have all of this in it. Right? So I'm gonna
get the column before we put it back in the game
column and I'm going to append the genre title
in it. So now if we look in the browser, da, da,
and I'm just gonna show you what this looks
like in HTML now. So that's what we made before.
Remember that's where we wrote in our HTML,
but with the thanks of JavaScript, I put in
five DS that have the class of genre column and
each one have another diviv with a class genre
title and the genre itself. So we've done it.
Okay. We've done our first for each in order
to create elements using JavaScript, take a
break here, let that soak in because we are
gonna be doing this again. Like I said to add
in each of the three questions into each column,
uh, and first off let's actually take
a mental break with some styling,
cuz styling's really nice. It's really easy.
And I'll allow our brains to maybe, you know,
slow down a, a bit before we
do another four each again. So
First things first, I'm just gonna
start the body up by getting rid of any
margin and padding, just to make sure that it's,
you know, spread out, uh, all over and I'm gonna
give it a background, color, RGB, this kind
it's RGB. It's kind of, well, I'll show you.
Well, six, it's kind of like a dark gray that
I'm gonna be using. And the font that I wanna use
in here is also all the font or the text,
sorry is gonna be white, just so it stands out.
The next thing I wanna do is actually use
flex box in order to make sure that everything
is displayed in the center. So by initializing
flex box, I can now use this command, which is
justify content to center. I won't be able to use
it without display flex. So make sure display flex
is there and align items center as well. That's
something I'm gonna use as well as flex direction,
flex direction column to make sure it's stacked
over each other. Okay. And great. I'm also going
to actually import a font family that is outside
of what we have. So if you go over to font or SIM,
so if you go over to Google fonts,
The font I wanna choose is called
Anton. So I'm just gonna search for it.
Uh, I've already been using some here. I
don't actually want any of these, so let's
go ahead and just remove Oswald, remove all
Anton. So this is the one that I want. So please
go ahead and click that and just select this
type. There's only one style and you can choose
whether to do it in your H share mile or CSS.
I'm gonna choose to put it in my CSS file. Just
gonna copy that. And at the top of this file,
I'm gonna import it like so as a URL.
And that just means that I can now use it
next to this. So great. So I can now use the
font family, Anton with Sans as a backup.
Wonderful. So that is my body. It just means
that I've kind of styled everything up to look
a bit more like this. The next thing I actually
wanna style is the, uh, game. So let's pick out
this div by the ID of game. So this means I
need to go for the ID of game, just like so,
and I'm just gonna say that everything in here
is gonna have the background color of RGB,
like this kind of, uh, darker grayish color.
Okay. So that's all I'm gonna do
for now. There were other thing I wanna do
is just make sure that all of these columns
are actually stacked next to each other. So
I'm also gonna use display flex to do this.
And that's what it should look like for now. Of
course, we are gonna be changing all of this up
a little bit later, so what's the next thing
we're gonna do? Well, let's actually get you,
um, inciting cards. In fact, while
we're here, let's actually just add
this styling for a card just so we can visually
see things a little bit nicer when they happen,
the width of a card I'm gonna hardcode is
160 pixels. The height I'm gonna hardcode
is 120 pixels. Uh, the background color. I'm just
gonna make it be that, that jeopardy blue, which
is RGB 26, 26, 2 55. Now I'm gonna make it look
beveled. So border left, I'm gonna say solid RGB.
Uh, and then it's gonna be like
this kind of lighter blue color
that I picked out earlier, and it's gonna be
10 pixels thick. And then I dunno if there's
a shorthand way to do this, but I'm lazy. So I'm
just gonna do that left. Right? And then we have
top and bottom, and then I'm just gonna
switch out the colors a little bit.
So I'm gonna make this like a
dark blue. I'm gonna make this
another tone of blue just to make it look
beveled. And then again, same here. So answer
great. Uh, I'm just gonna make sure all the text
is centered to, and the font size I'm gonna use
for the cards. It's gonna be a hundred pixels.
Okay. It's gonna be really big. Let's give it
a margin of five pixels. So each card is gonna
have a margin of five pixels and some padding.
And I'm also gonna give the line. I'm gonna change
the line height, uh, of the font. Okay. So that's
all I've done. So we created a class of card. Now
let's actually get you creating some cards. So
we've appended the column inside the game.
The next thing we need to do is actually work
with the questions. So at the moment we are still
in this object, right? We've picked out the genre.
The next thing I wanna do is pick out this array
of questions and we're gonna use four each again
to loop over each item in this array. So hopefully
that makes sense based on what we have done
previously. So as we are currently for each
in, so we're in the, for each loop currently,
thanks to this. Let's get a category and all
I'm gonna do is get the category questions
this time. So the array and for each item or
each question, sorry, let's call it a question.
What do we wanna happen? Well, as I said, I wanna
make a card. So document create element div,
and I'm just gonna call this literally card, just
like, so, and this time I'm gonna go classless,
add, uh, cards, cuz that's the, the class that
we have just created here. So that's what I
wanna apply to this div. And of course we need
to put it in the column. So let's grab the column
and use append and I'm gonna pen the card.
Okay, great. You can use a pen child. Append
allows you to add multiple things, but
you can use a pen child if you want to,
if you just want append one thing, which
I guess technically we are doing here,
so great. That's what we are doing at the moment.
We won't see much cuz it's just an empty div.
However, we can put some text in here. Uh, in fact
maybe let's do it by the level. So we're looping
over each item in the questions array, right? So
I wanna get each questions level and if it's easy.
So right here after we put in the
card, if question level equals
easy, well then I wanna get the card
and it's in a HTML or in a text,
you can do whatever really
in a H in a text, same thing.
Maybe let's keep it all consistent though.
So I know we did it somewhere here in a HTML.
We're just gonna hard code 100 cuz that's how
many points you get for answering an easy question
and let's do the same for the others. So if
it's medium, I wanna put in the inner HTML 200
and if it's hard, I'm gonna
give us 300 points. Okay?
So that's literally all I'm doing.
So now if I look in here, da da,
that's what we have made. That's our card. And
that's the inner HTML that we've given our card.
This is looking great. Now, if you watched
my tutorial on making a word association
game in that game, we actually, you know, had
functions and we passed through a lot of stuff
into them in order to work with events
listeners. So we passing through a lot of, um,
information into functions. This time, I'm
gonna show you a different way to do this.
You can actually set attributes to elements
so that you can add more data to them that
you can pick out later and you can
do so using the set attribute method.
So this is what I'm gonna be showcasing for us
today. Okay, I'm gonna get up this because we're
gonna be needing to see exactly what I am adding
to each div at the moment. Each of these divs just
has the class card and the inner HTML of 100, 200
or 300, I'm gonna be adding a lot more information
to these with a help of set attribute. Of
course, this does mean that someone could,
you know, inspect the page and cheat a jeopardy,
but you know, this is just for fun. So, but yeah,
just be aware of that. So I want to essentially
append all the information about my question
to this div so that we flip it. We still have
access to that information. So like I said,
we're gonna use set attribute to do this. So I'm
gonna grab the card. So literally the card that we
created, which is the diviv and that we added
the classes to, and then we put in the column
and then we added a HTML to next. We're gonna
use set attribute in order to add a data
question, which is going to just be the questions
question, right? Because we're looping over
This questions, array, which we called
question, this is a question, which is why
I've said question, question. I mean, sadly,
you know, it's just worked out that way that
we have to use question question next. We're
gonna have question. Correct. And we're gonna
go into the question object and get level and as
well as the first answer in the second answer.
So that's what we've done here. And in fact, if
I show you what this looks like, if I refresh it,
you'll now see that each div not only has the
class of card, not only has the NEX content of
a hundred, it also has now data question and the
actual question, how many players in a football
team, how many seconds an hour and how many
people in China. So that information is all
attached to that div that we can't visually see,
but it exists. So I'm gonna do the same. So card
set, attribute for the other things I said. So
we've got the data question, let's have the data,
correct. Which is gonna be question
correct. And then also the answers,
right? So set, attribute data. Uh, let's
do answer one and go question answers
and then go into the first, get the first item
from this array. So this one, and then let's
get the second one as well. Tim's gonna copy
<affirmative> I'm just gonna copy this line.
Get the second item by using the index value of
one to enter this, to get the second item in the
array. Because as we know arrays use indexes. Now
I'm gonna do one last thing and you set attribute
to add the data value and you might be thinking
like, oh, what, but we've used all the information
we can in here. What, what else do you wanna
do? Right. Well, I actually wanna get this value
and also set it to the di so that when we flip
the card, we still know the value of the card
and I can do so with a function so I can get the
card and use, get inner HTML and call it. So call
the method in order to get the inner HTML of this
diviv, which in this case is a hundred, the case
is 200 and this case is
300.
So that's pretty neat if I do say so myself. So
now if I refresh this and we look on any one of
these, you will see the data question, data,
answer one data, answer corrects and the data
value. Why is the data answer two, not being
added, ah, it's cuz data being overwritten.
So TA we have all that information as well
as the data value now to our disposal. Great.
So now let's get to flipping these cards. So
I'm gonna do so by adding an event listener to
our card. So card add event listener and on
click of the card. I just want to flip the
card. So this is a call back function. We need to
write this function and if we click on any card,
this will be caught. Okay. But only if we click
on the card, so let's go ahead and do that now.
So we are done with this function. It is a long
one. So the function ad category is now done.
The next function we're gonna write is
the function. So function flip cut card.
So what do we want to happen when we flip the
card? Well, we just wanted to visually look like
the flip the card, right? So in fact, I just wanna
get rid of the styling of the div. So I wanna get
rid of the styling and just make it look like I
flip the card by adding some animations maybe,
and then, you know, having, uh, the question,
show up with the two options of the answers.
So let's do it. So I'm gonna get this
card. So this element that I've clicked on,
I'm gonna get it in a HTML and I'm literally just
going to put an empty string. Okay. So it's kind
of like a cheat way to empty it out. Now, the next
thing I wanna do is create a, uh, diviv that I've
called text display so that we can display
the text of the question in and then kind of
style up a little bit. So I'm gonna use, create
element and I'm gonna create a div to do this.
Okay. So now that we've created the diviv, once
again, I'm gonna get text display and I'm gonna
use class list, add to add a class list that
we are yet to write. We can use text display,
or maybe let's choose card text, just like
So, so we're putting in the text display. This
is good. The next thing I wanna do is add two
buttons. So once again, I'm gonna use document
create element, and this time I'm gonna create
a button element. And once we have created that
button, I'm just gonna call this fast button,
cuz I'm not very imaginative, but we actually
need two buttons. So first button and second
button again, just using the create element
method to create a button element. So once we have
those, well, of course, we're gonna have to add,
uh, classes to them. So thank you very much,
but this first button's gonna have the class
first button and then the second one is gonna
have the class. You guess it second button.
So just like so, so we've added the classes and
now we just need to add some texts into these,
right? So I'm gonna go first button in a HTML
and we are going to get this, whatever we clicked
this, get attribute, gonna get the attributes,
have a look again. What's to our disposal,
get attribute the view data, answer one,
answer one. And of course for the second one,
we'll get data, answer two for the second
button. So we created the buttons.
We've added classes to the buttons.
We've also set the inner HTML of the buttons to
either have one answer or another. And of course
we need to put these buttons into whatever
we click. So we're gonna use this again,
this keyword, I'm gonna do a pen and
I'm actually gonna pen the text display
And then the first button and then
the second button. Okay, great.
So that is looking good. We of course also need
to get the, uh, we need to add in a HTML. We need
to actually add the, uh, question itself. So we're
gonna use get attribute to get the data question,
making sure to spell it exactly the same
as we saved it. So data question like so
great. So this should now look good. Let's
test it out. So let's or something's gone wrong
event. Listener is not a function. Okay. Card.
Our ad event listener should be a capital
L here. Okay. So if you click on one now,
so that is disappearing and we are getting the
question and we are getting two buttons. Of course
we need to do some styling cuz this is not looking
good. So one thing I can actually do is change.
We're probably gonna have to change the font
size in here so we can do so using font style,
Uh, this style font size and let's
change it to be 15 pixels. So again,
we're just using JavaScript to do this and we're
also going to change the line height from here.
Line height is gonna be 30 pixels. So now if
we click on one of these amazing, <affirmative>
amazing. So that is looking much better. There's
of course still some things we need to do. One
thing we need to do is actually, um, add an on
click to these buttons to handle it as the correct
answer or not. And also I wanna disable clicking
on any of these. If we are currently answering a
question, right, we don't wanna cheat, no cheating
aloud. And then we also wanna add one to the
score. If the correct answer is clicked. So I'm
gonna show you how to do all of that first off,
however, let's get to styling some things up.
The first thing that I'm gonna start up is the
buttons. So let's do that now. Just gonna make
some space and great. So the first button,
I'm just gonna give this a background color of
RGB, 2, 4, 1 7 1 2, 4. We're gonna make it look
kind of like retro. And then of course the second
button as well needs to have some styling two.
So one let's go with 1 90, 57 37. So we just added
two colors to the buttons. We can't let's keep
it this kind of retro style though. Cause I'm
kind of strangely into it. You don't have to,
of course you can choose to get rid of it if
you wish. Okay. While we are here, let's also
start the genre title. So the class of this was
genre title. If I remember that correctly, I'm
gonna give it a background color of the same blue
that we had. So RGB 2 6, 2 6, 2, 5, 5, like so,
uh, let's text a line center. Oops, text
Line center. Let's make the font size.
I'm gonna make it 28 pixels and let's give it
padding five pixels. Okay. And then also a margin
five pixels too. So that just looks a little bit
more like this, just like the game. Great. Okay.
So we've done that. The next thing I wanna do
is handle the click. So let's do that. So now
what you wanna do, do you know, actually, before
we move on to adding the event listeners for the
two buttons, I'm actually gonna say that if we
flip the card, I wanna again, every single card,
every single one and remove the event listener.
So I'm gonna use using document query, select all
and look off anything with the class of card. So
that'll be all, all of these cards, okay. All of
these. And I'm gonna remove the event listener
for them, but only on this flip. So all cards,
I'm gonna save this as, and I think we need to
make this an array. I'm gonna make an array from
these apologies. If not, make sure
this query is selected all. Uh,
and then we're gonna get
all the cards and for each
Card, just gonna get each card and remove event
listener. And I'm gonna remove the click and I'm
gonna remove the flip card so that now if a card
is flipped, we can't click any of them. The flip
is disabled. This is cool. Right. And I only want
to enable it again if we choose an answer. So now
let's handle the clicks of the buttons. So I'm
gonna write another function. This function's
gonna be called, uh, let's call it, get result.
Okay. So just like, so us move all of this. Oops.
Let's just move all of this up a little bit. So
what do I want to happen? Well, I want to, if I
click on the button, right? So let's add an event
listener to the first do up here. First button,
add event listener. If I click on it, then I want
to get results just as they call back function.
Okay. And then let's do the same for
the second button as well. So they're
both going to essentially call this function
if we click on them and if we click on it,
I wanna get this or whatever. I clicked,
whatever button I clicked. I wanna get as
parent and as parent as the card. So if we have a
look at here, the button lives in the div with a
class of cards, I wanna get the parent of this.
Right. I wanna get the parent. So this parent
element. So I'm just gonna show you the console
log. Uh, let's say this is something constant
card of button to be really precise. Cuz that's
what we're getting. We're getting the card
the button belongs to. And then do we have any
other console logs in here? I feel like we do.
You do not. Okay. So here's our console log. So if
I click on this click on a button, it'll show me
it's parent, which is this car that belongs
to, and you'll see all that data that we need
to work with. Okay. So that's quite cool.
It's carry on. So to get the result, well,
what I'm gonna do is say if card of button
and then I'm gonna use get attribute to get
the attribute of, well, I guess we want to get the
data correct answer. Right? We wanna get the data.
Correct. Which is 11. So we know that this
is the correct answer and we wanna make
sure it's the same as the inner HTML
of the button. So if that equals this
inner HTML, then we know it's a correct answer.
Right. So then we're gonna get this score and we
are going to essentially add the score by
getting again, um, the data value of the button,
which is why we save the data value. So there
we go. So I'm gonna, once again, go card button,
get attribute, data value. However, it's a
stirring rights. We need to pass this through
pass inch to make sure that it's a number type
and then we're gonna add it to the score. So score
plus the value and we're gonna
assign it to the variable score.
Okay. So are we actually saving score
anywhere here? I don't believe we are.
So I'm gonna go let score equal zero to start.
Okay. So that's what we're doing. If it's,
if the answer's correct, we're gonna add
something to the score. We're then gonna
show the score in the browser. Cause we're
actually not doing that yet. So just get the
variable of score after we've added the data
value to it and then show it in here. The next
thing I'm gonna do is actually, uh, get the
card button and I'm going to also class list.
Add I'm gonna add a correct answer class so that
we can change that symbolize. That's correct.
Let's go like an orange or something and then
let's, uh, actually remove everything in the card
itself. We're gonna remove the question. We're
gonna remove these two buttons and we're just
gonna show the value that we want if it's correct.
So to do this, I'm actually going to leave a
little bit of time, so it's not so abrupt. Okay.
So I'm gonna use a set time out to do this and
then we're gonna use a wild loop to essentially
remove children. We're gonna remove the last child
and then the last child, until there's no children
left in the parent div. So while card of button,
first child exists, it's gonna keep doing it until
there's no first child. Right? So while that is
true, we're gonna get the card button, remove
child card button, last child. So we're gonna
essentially, if that makes sense, we're gonna keep
looping and get rid of the last child, get rid of
the last child, get rid of last child until the
last child is the first child get rid of that. And
then there'll be no flash child and this will kind
of, um, finish running. Okay. So we're gonna do
that. We're gonna move everything in it. Uh, and
we're gonna do this after a hundred milliseconds
and then we're just going to get the card button.
And then the ntml like we said, we're just gonna
make it the value. So get attribute data value.
We're just gonna show how many points we want.
So that's all happens. All of this is what
happens if you know the answer's correct else.
We're gonna say wrong answer. So I'm essentially
going to just take this line, but this time wrong
answer. So that'll be like a reddish color. Maybe
I haven't decided yet. And this time we're gonna
do set time out. Uh, and then we're actually still
gonna remove everything. But this time we're just
going to add a zero, cuz we want zero points. We
can do it as a number if you want. It's totally up
to you and we're gonna do this again after
milliseconds. Okay, great. And then afterwards
we're gonna add back. Well actually we need to
add back all the event listeners to the cards,
but also we're gonna remove the event listener
for this specific card because we are done with
it. Remove event listener, click flip card.
We're done with this card. We've got our points
no more cheating. And this just means that
actually, um, let's perhaps do it up here.
So once again, document queries, get all the
cards again. So everything with the class name
of card and I'm gonna save this as all cards,
make an array from this again, I'm not really
sure if I have to do this, but I'm doing it
now. I've committed. Uh, and then all cards for
each card. I'm going to well, just add back
in the, remove the event listener. Okay,
great. And then just some final styling to add
the correct answer and incorrect answer. So
correct answer. It's a correct answer. I want the
background color to change to RGB 1 8 6 1 8 6 24.
And if it's a wrong answer, then I wanna change
the background color to be RGB 2, 2, 1 6 4, 5, 6.
Great. So now let's share good art. So this one,
when is Christmas? I know it's here. Yay. It's
correct. So we see the value. We get a hundred
of the score and the background's turned yellow.
Now this one, what is the cast of Saudi
Arabia? I'm gonna go Jed. That's the wrong
answer by the way, but I should get
a red zero points and zero is added.
So this is looking wonderful. And of course I
can't click on anything else until I answer this
question and then I can click on another question.
So even when this is here, can't click on anything
Superman. Wonderful. So this is looking
fantastic. We have now finished our jeopardy game,
so I hope you've enjoyed this tutorial. I've
really enjoyed making this for you. I mean,
I think we've done a really good job at
this. It is kind of foolproof. Of course,
if you, uh, come across any bugs, then
let me know, but I'm quite happy with
this. Wow. Okay. And of course, please feel
free to start this up. However you wish that
part is totally up to you. Thanks so much again
for watching and I hope to see you again soon.